faccio una premessa al volo perché mi
sembra opportuno farla avevo detto che
non avrei più fatto Gameplay ma avevo
anche detto che sarebbero state delle
piccole eccezioni e ovviamente Questa è
una di quelle siamo ragazzi su
Gossip Girl hanno fatto il 3D Stars Non
ho idea di cosa aspettarmi Sinceramente
già lo sfondo promette molto bene nuova
partita sembra di essere tornato ai
vecchi tempi Bellissima sta roba Beh lo
so che l'aspettavate tutti Sono contento
Anch'io sono sono nostalgico Ok anche io
ogni tanto vivo di nostalgia come
facevano un essere umano hanno messo al
cinematica stavolta e la Madonna
no vabbè è partito come Skyrim
Bellissima la partenza come Skyrim
bellissimo Ragazzi sto avendo delle
vipes che non so che dire ci sono due
capre e nonno Chuck in mezzo vabbè sì
vado subito alla torre basta che mi fai
alzare Sì scendi dalla mia carrozza
Skyrim E vai La Torre va bene
caprastello vamos Minchia raga Sono
troppo gasato e dovevo andare subito
alla torre ma ovviamente sto gioco è
fatto al contrario cioè nel senso tutto
quello che ti dicono di fare non lo
dovresti fare Salve vediamo subito di
capire in che Mood siamo perché qua
ancora non è da un po' che non ci gioco
capite che un anziano come me deve
riprendere il ritmo quindi vabbè Salve
Allora se no Ah ci sono anche le
statuette nascoste va bene Se non erro
si lecca con e esatto e le cose si
appiccicano quindi è esattamente come
gli altri got Simulator va bene
scivolare Premiere vicino ai cavi
elettrici per scivolare Soldier Oh mio
dio Cos'è Tony Hawk Pro skating Ma cos'è
sta roba
Con quale fisica me lo stai dicendo
Vabbè poteva andare anche peggio voglio
dire questo vedendo
posso leccare anche le galline Sì posso
Va bene Allora ci sono un sacco di robe
che si possono fare prima di continuare
entro qua dentro e poi va dalla torre
ragazzi così non ci perdiamo troppo Va
bene comunque promette Molto bene
ragazzi per adesso sento del rock and
roll e questa è la casa della nonna
quindi non so come sia c'è un bunker
cazzo è Sixty Seconds
Oddio
è diventato un gioco a pixel porca
[ __ ] oh oh oh hai rotto che palle son
due ore che mi spam Mannaggia chi t'è
muta poi perché è diventato tutto
pissellato ragazzi che è successo
Scusate Allora io tra l'altro sto
andando ancora ma quante ce ne sono di
vecchie basta Allora lecco la nonna
vamos vamos nonna versus nonna se ce n'è
un'altra te la lancio
Ok
Eccola Porca vacca non mancava Quante
nonne Meno male ragazzi che non c'è la
vita in sto gioco sennò sarei morto da
una vita sono incastrato nel pavimento
basta Fatemi uscire come si esce io
santo Benedetto Allora vediamo di fare
le cose come ci avevano detto di farla
all'inizio anche se effettivamente un
po' tardi
sincronizza e ti passa si scrive È
Assassin's Creed sta roba cos'è Eh vabbè
the grinta Ah mi fa vedere tutte le zone
circostanti va bene Sì è come Assassin's
Creed ragazzi è molto è molto strano
dirlo Perché in genere i sequel sono
peggiori dei dei precedenti Ma questo
Sembra fatto veramente bene quindi non
so e non voglio dire ancora niente ma mi
sembra veramente fatto bene ragazzi
Allora sali di Rango Beh che posso
salire di Rango questo gioco Cioè mi
sembra un po' eccessivo posso entrare
qua dentro visto che ha aperto la porta
sì Non mi ricordo cosa c'era nel
nell'altro
Oh
Salve
Cos'è che è successo qua Cos'è sta roba
sono probabilmente tutti richiami ad
altri videogiochi non è che li posso
riconoscere tutti i ragazzi Quindi non
so se mi sto perdendo qualcosa c'è una
porta incatenata vamos e la magica porta
come ci arrivo tra l'altro Devo
scavalcare qua Va bene Parkour Ah ricevi
di compenso che non avevo visto
mi dà un potere cosa succede
abbiamo tolto una catena fin qua quante
ce ne sono un miliardo di catene come
faccio a levarle tutte
[Musica]
Sì mi sembra
mi stanno pimpando la capra cosa succede
Cos'è Hogwarts sto poco cos'è che il
calice di fuoco Cos'è sta roba yah sono
morto io e tutto questo caprastello
la sorellanza dimenticata Ma cosa ho
sbloccato devo andare qua per sbloccarlo
assorbi saggezza va bene club privato
cosa ho preso
istinti disponibili Esegui un salto
triplo a ti dà punti Pensavo mi avesse
sbloccato delle robe invece no non
c'entra niente Warning
sembra pericolosa non sono molto
convinto di fare quello che sto per fare
ma
me ne vado Arrivederci
io mi allontanerei
E va bene così ragazzi puzzo Gli devo
lavare Eccoci
ha funzionato veramente ragazzi non
puzzo più incredibile vi sentite
tranquilli voi che andate tipo in giro
con le dinamiti non me ne frega nulla
credo che sia morta Raga non ne sono
convintissimo Ma allora cos'è c'è un
alveare No una mela d'Oro Mi scusi posso
è sceso Dio a dirmi che non lo posso
fare un po' come mi succede nel
quotidiano ma lo faccio scendere per
altri motivi posso prendere questo lo
prendo bellissimo No non ho capito bene
cosa fa il frutto proibito Ragazzi
scusate vediamo
fa saltare la gente va bene lo prendo
Salve Oddio Ma quanto è grossa sta tizia
quanto è grossa
Porca [ __ ] perché è gigante sta tizia
che cosa c'è di qua Ok ecco l'olio
Ragazzi c'è l'olio Allora se prendo una
tanica teoricamente sono una capra
d'olio sono una Salve sono una capra
d'oro va bene posso prendere un oggetto
per prendere l'olio tipo mi serve perché
devo portare
ok Devo incanalare no no no no
dio Fermati Dio Hahaha No perché mi ha
dato fuoco perché ce l'hai con me Dio
vado a fuoco Senza un apparente motivo
Buongiorno Qual è il posto migliore per
andare a fuoco un benzinaio giustamente
posso provare
la risposta è no Allora vediamo se qua
sento qualcosa scintillare quando sono
andato porca di quella [ __ ] mi sono
cagato addosso qua sento una musica che
mi piace
sali in cima una cosa devo fare qualcosa
è la radio che fa questo Porca [ __ ]
Questa esplosioni Ah posso guidare sta
roba ok posso guidare la macchina questa
cosa mi è nuova ragazzi che imprunement
che ha fatto sto gioco Eccoci qua
Aspetta che devo si può interrare una
ragazzi si può E vabbè si può spaccare
tutto in sto gioco incredibile mi serve
vedere se questa qua funziona Se li do
l'olio così vediamo se
è caricati da che parte li devo infilare
da qua No secondo me il fatto che stia
andando a fuoco non è un bellissimo
segno non dovrebbe funzionare dalla dove
li metto gli oggetti Come faccio a
mettere gli oggetti per scalarli scusate
kaput [ __ ] Allora se Attiva
teoricamente dovrebbe funzionare vediamo
se riesco a scalare un essere umano
vediamo se riesco
Yes è uscito grosso
senza casalinga dove è uscito
Ma dov'è
me lo sono perso non ho capito Sono
entrato io sono che succede Non ho
capito ma ha funzionato ha scalato sta
tizia
Eccola Ah eccolo
Ah quella rimpicciolita quindi la devo
mettere da dietro da davanti per
ingrandirla va bene Effettivamente credo
di essere diventato un pelo più grosso
giorno Posso unirmi sono un po'
ingombrante ma teoricamente ci sto
vediamo
Sì ci dovrei stare Salve
Queste sono i Daft Punk questi e c'è Dio
che mi sta toccando non è colpa mia è
colpa sua prendetevela con lui ho visto
comunque dei porno molto più volgari di
questo secondo me questa roba è un po'
finire su YouTube Però vabbè la
mettiamocelo lo stesso Sì sì adesso me
ne vado adesso me ne vado fammi capire
se posso fare qualcosa sopra la
Mongolfiera No eh Me ne vado è stato
molto divertente ci ho deltaplano
forse lo posso prendere al volo raga'
cioè in realtà sì questo gossip
Simulator è fatto per Ste cagate quindi
si può prendere al volo al 100%. solo
che devo Ma quanto grosso sto gioco
no Oh merda
Ok ok Come ci si non mi ricordo come ci
si siede in sto gioco Aspetta che forse
Ecco qua a posto sono un vero spettatore
di questa fiera dell'expo della salute
del cibo
non credo che questo sia il cibo più
salutare che abbia mai visto a
prescindere dal fatto che sia io qua
dentro
va bene perché questa è un'altra Torre
serve per sbloccare le aree della mappa
vennero sblocco anche questa si può
sincronizza bellissima Ragazzi ma
comunque io veramente non so cosa a
distanza di anni non so neanche più cosa
dire di sto gioco è incredibile Cioè qua
c'è la piscina c'è l'IKEA l'hanno
chiamata sverchia c'è l'IKEA in goat
Simulator non sto male devo andarci non
so se in questo episodio nel prossimo ma
ci vado Fammi entrare posso entrare Qua
c'è un altro potere che mi sblocca se
entro qua dentro chiedo Non lo so sì c'è
un altro potere Attenzione ragazzi Qua
c'è roba no Dio non è il momento l'ho
sbloccato il potere
Vabbè ricevi una ricompensa vai
ricompensami
anche qua avevo un'altra catena
Minchia raga Ma quante Quante torri ci
sono incredibile Cioè ci sono ancora 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 non una decina di Torri ci
sono mica è impossibile che questo gioco
ste robe non le ho viste neanche nel
derringer ragazzi volevo solo dirvi
questo abbiamo visto un'infarinatura che
quello che è ancora Simulator quello
nuovo e poi il prossimo episodio La
prossima settimana faccio uscire una
settimana Eh più o meno ci vediamo la
prossima settimana vediamo cosa c'è al
piano di sopra niente ragazzi Questo
video è piaciuto lasciate un commento mi
piace anche ai vari Social che mi
aiutate in descrizione Se non siete
iscritti iscrivetevi al mio telecomando
quello storico Dovete ancora essere qua
sono 10 anni che è sempre lo stesso
ormai Ragazzi sto per fare 10 anni col
canale Eh al 8 dicembre Ricordatelo 10
anni Il telecomando è sempre quello e
come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video
bella ragazzi
[Musica]